Từ thằng điên xưa đời bộ xung một số điệu của người định một số tảm về sự phản vì pham hành chính trường
nếu vận giá thông được bộ, chưa điểm phố hôi điểm giếp lại xe đang được bộ công ma lấy kiến.
Tuy nhiên, thời gian qua, số điện một số thông tin chưa chính xác, ra hiểu làm trong số lợt.
Chứ tình như ngày, cô kể sẽ xưa thông đã lên tiếng làm gió khẳng định sự thảo không,
nâng mất sự phản, đời với các hành vi bị pham giá thông.
Đời giống quay trùi là để xuất điều trình thầm quyền sự phản tiền của các cán bộ,
chỉ có mọi như giân đang thi hành công vụ.
Từ tối đàn năm trong điên đồng lên bày trưởng dưới,
đồng thời cập nhật in thầm quyền của các chiến xanh như độ trường trạm trường của mạnh cấp sáng.
Theo cầu cây giữa thông thì đây không phải là việc tăng mất phản đời với tình lỗi vi phản.
Mà là mở giống thầm quyền quyền quyền sự phản của lượng thực thiện nhạm vụ.
Puy định này được cho là mang lại lợi ít thịt thượng trường dưới gián.
Khi với các lỗi có không phản dưới bày trưởng dưới.
Nguyên phản của tiền nộ phản triết tại trộ thế quên tiếp sự phản không lập biên bàn có phần đường dành hoa thuộc hành chính.